nate silver who everybody loves this guy
right he predicted the last election
he's a big numbers guy who now is part
of ESPN he's doing sports he got out of
the political world basically and he's
doing sports but he did have some
interesting thoughts on 2014 basically
that the Republicans are going to win
back the Senate which is a scary scary
thought we've got a bunch of quotes
actually we think the Republicans are
now slight favourites to win at least
six seats and capture the chamber the
Democrats position has deteriorated
somewhat since last summer with
President Obama's approval ratings down
to 42 or 43 percent which is down from
about forty five percent and as compared
with twenty ten or twenty twelve the GOP
has done a better job of recruiting
credible candidates with some exceptions
okay so silver does urge some caution
there these aren't you know mind-blowing
numbers that Republicans are
automatically going to win but it is
sort of interesting and what I sort of
glean into this is that this is an
Obamacare thing that the Republicans
have sort of won the messaging somehow
on that we can't have socialized
medicine and not everyone has a right to
health care and all that do you think
that's what this is about that they've
somehow scared enough people to think
they have to be voting for them oh
definitely I think the people are ya oh
my God my healthcare chains that might
it might get cancelled people don't know
what what's going on was that people
even know what's in their health care
plan till they get sick so everybody's
running scared everybody's running free
but Nate Silver you know it's though I
think a Democrats whale reacted to this
right because he's not saying that's
gonna happen said there's a slight
chance that that might have but that's
how much stock people put in what he's
because of what happened last time with
Romney but I don't don't forget that he
also nates over was wrong in 2012 no
2010 I think when he predicted that the
Democrats would lose it again the Senate
and they ended up gaining seats yeah so
he's that always correct yeah so well
that is a good point nobody's always
correcting of course these number guys
that uh you know that's why he's working
for ESPN now it's a lot easier dealing
at sports numbers than political numbers
uh but what I was thinking about this
was that the Republicans as far as i can
tell have no particular message other
than everything's against Obama so is is
anyone fired up for the Republicans
that's what I think is interesting here
p
are saying we're going to vote for the
Republicans in 2014 but is anyone
actually voting for them or they're just
voting against Obama I think it a lot
this happens a lot with midterm
elections people to do tend to vote
against what the current status quo is
and the Republicans do have a strong
message in you know attaching their
horse and carriage to the Affordable
Care Act they do have a lot of messaging
that they can use and they wasn't wrong
in predicting and he wasn't he was he
was actually I think maybe dead on in
predicting that 2014 we might see
Republicans take over the Senate the
good thing that this does for the
Democrats though and you'll already see
this happening they can take this
message exact and they can use it to
raise funds and fund these campaigns but
we do have about ten Senate races that
are really important for the Republicans
really important for the Democrats we
have Democrats who are stepping down
south dakota is an example you've got
senator Johnson who is retiring and
you've got a really popular former
governor running in that state Mike
rounds could could take over that seat
that gives you a Republican North
Carolina is going to be an interesting
race Kay Hagan one that Senate seat from
Elizabeth Dole back in two thousand
eight when North Carolina was a blue
state for the first time in my lifetime
and it went back to read in 2012 so Kay
Hagan is going to have a tough race
looks like Thom Tillis is going to be
maybe one of the best possible
candidates I go to speaker the house
there in North Carolina there are some
people who are it's a risk for some of
the Democrats but that's what happens in
midterm elections we've seen it history
repeats itself we've seen it over and
over again and I think Nate was actually
making kind of a safe prediction and
suggesting that it might happen
interesting so do you think this is sort
of shows the strength of our democracy
in a weird way that in the midterms we
do often vote against the incumbent
president because it is a little bit of
check of powers which we seem to have
completely lost uh I would in normal
times I would say yes but I would say
that the Republican Party has gone so
far off the rails that now the Democrats
are Republicans and so we're not
actually getting a gut so as far as a
government that's representative of the
people's will we certainly don't have
that right now at all I don't think I
mean look when ninety percent of the
people want a gun
restrictions and gun legislation didn't
happen what does that mean that means
that our government we're like it's a
banana republic you know it's like what
who would this they're only serving
their donors they're not serving us
which means that what we really need is
a different kind of campaign financing I
come back to this all the time when it
comes to politics yeah so campaign
finance which we talk everything we do
here the young turks is about money in
politics and who's bought and sold why
do we not even have any discussion about
campaign finance anywhere we used to
have that mccain feingold thing what
happened that thing disappeared and now
it literally is not in the news anywhere
because the people who are supposed to
be talking about it is the media right
the Fourth Estate right and they're not
talking about it because the people who
pay their salary and sign their checks
want to have influence in politics they
now work for these major corporations
for instance right so Brian Williams and
David Gregory they work for General
Electric a major defense contractor they
of course want to have influence on the
government so they're not going to go on
their new show and say hey we got to get
what we're doing is horrible we have to
get rid of it and by the way the Iraq
war is and we process profited
off it so they're not going to do any of
that and that's the problem the people
the criminals bought the news media
after they bought the Congress so now
there's no watchdog anymore and that's
why the only people talking about it is
us yeah well okay so that's speaking of
us are is the online news thing now
we're slightly off when we started here
but is the online news thing just to
wrap this all up are we the only estate
that's left yet can stop this thing I
hope I hope so because if you really
look at the way the world is working
especially this younger generation
that's where we're getting our news
we're looking to the people online to
inform us and talk to us and if we as an
online community end up getting more
attention then ultimately don't they
have to follow suit doesn't mainstream
media have to follow suit it's it's
terrifying to think about now because of
the overt when with a supreme court
overturned campaign financing and we
created all these super PACs it wasn't
it was basically like money laundering
for campaign finance and it's difficult
to discuss it now because you have to
dig in a different way dig really deeply
to find out who is financing what and
how and whom well said and I can promise
you guys that we're not bought and sold
and don't trust the Democrats don't
trust the Republicans trust yourself
okay